si le changement de méthode consiste à
demander à celui qui est certainement le
meilleur spécialiste de la politique de
la ville de travailler pendant six mois
avec des élus des acteurs associatifs et
puis au bout du compte de le qualifier
mâles blancs et d'orangés son rapport au
rancart alors oui un changement de
méthode et je trouve ça assez concernant
pour tout vous dire voilà on attendait
des annonces alors borloo parce que vous
le souhaitez mais s'est dit satisfait
elle dit que tout elle et moi je vous
dis ce que j'ai ressenti je pense que
cette expression est quand même assez
hallucinante dans la bouche du chef de
l'état eu égard à la personne qui est
concerné d'ailleurs jean louis borloo et
quand on sait le travail qu'il a fait il
est venu voir boulot ici au sénat pour
parler des finances des collectivités
locales les plus pauvres je les écoutais
pendant une heure et demie je suis lui
transmettre des informations dont ils
avaient besoin
je savais qu'il avait envie de dire des
choses relativement forte il les a dit
dans ce rapport on peut en contester
certains points pour bien évidemment
mais je trouve que la manière dont il a
été considéré ce matin est un peu
regrettable et quand un changement de
méthode mais écoutez c'est de la com ce
qu'on a vu ce matin je pense que tous
les élus de banlieue aujourd'hui sont
frustrés parce que on attend
effectivement des actes alors cette
réunion est le lieu pourquoi parce que
depuis l'été dernier effectivement il ya
une grande frustration avec les annonces
qui ont concerné notamment les emplois
aidés
les associations et l inquiétude les
élus locaux on leur demande encore de
faire des efforts et même dans les
villes les plus difficiles et donc tout
ça ça a commencé à bouillir dans la
cocotte minute
et donc là on attendait effectivement
des décisions une ligne directrice et on
a un exercice de comme on ne dure a dit
il n'y a pas de plan banlieues alors y'a
pas de plan banlieues mais il y aura
quoi à la place